I do not believe that Donald Trump wants
to face Bernie in the Democratic primary
and you can just smell Trump's fear of
Bernie Sanders being the nominee in a
tweet he sent out yesterday afternoon
where he said quote Wow crazy Bernie
Sanders is surging in the polls looking
very good against his opponents in the
do-nothing Party so what does this mean
stay tuned Trump very afraid by the way
the do-nothing Party that has done
something that was only done twice
before which is impeach is sitting
president Bernie Sanders by the way
tweeting back it means you're going to
lose more and more people are contacting
me suggesting that if bernie is the
nominee Donald Trump would skip the
debates I don't know about that and and
to be honest I don't think that that's a
possibility
only if Bernie is the nominee because
Donald Trump is increasingly incoherent
it wouldn't shock me if Trump skipped
the debates calling them rigged and
faked in a number of circumstances with
a number of different Democratic
nominees what what it does seem though
is that Donald Trump is certainly
preparing more to run against Joe Biden
as far as we know Trump didn't go to
another country and say I will withhold
military aid unless you get me dirt and
smears on Bernie or on Warren or
whatever as far as we know right now he
was doing that about Biden so there's
the indication that he believes he's
going to be running against Biden and to
some degree has a plan for running
against Biden with Bernie it's going to
be crazy Bernie we will never be
socialist Bernie wants to give everybody
free stuff that's the repertoire against
Bernie and I think it falls short of
what Trump has planned for fighting
Biden going after Biden about hunter
Biden and burries m'a muddling the
entire impeachment and Ukraine thing by
pulling in but what you know Biden's
involvement there and hunter Biden's
involvement it's much easier for Trump
to muddle it up with Joe Biden than it
is with Bernie Sanders now remember that
Donald Trump already started hinting at
maybe he'll debate maybe he won't weeks
ago when he tweeted in mid-december I
look very much forward to debating
whoever the lucky person is who stumbles
across the finish line
the little watch do-nothing Democrat
debates my record is so good on the
capital II economy and all else
including debating that perhaps I would
consider more than three debates the
problem is that the so called Commission
on Presidential Debates is stacked with
Trump haters and never Trump errs three
years ago they were forced to publicly
apologize for modulating my microphone
in the first debate against crooked
Hillary as president the debates are up
to me and there are many options
including doing them directly and
avoiding the nasty politics of this very
biased Commission I will make a decision
at an appropriate time but in the
meantime the Commission on presidential
debates is not authorized speak for me
or Republicans so this is already on the
table it's already something Trump is
potentially setting up in the way that
his followers will say damn right he's
skipping the debates if he chooses to
instead of being concerned that wait a
second why is the sitting president
refusing to debate the opponent and not
some unknown third party polling 1% but
choosing to debate the winner of the
Democratic primary that should be the
reaction but Trump is very good at
priming his supporters to cheer on
whatever decision he ultimately makes
also I I don't know that for our
audience we need to get into this other
part trump's nickname of bernie as crazy
bernie it may stick trumps the power of
trumps nicknaming is is good is high but
it all started with framing Bernie as a
socialist as a crazy far left guy of
course
Bernie's policies are simply called
established government policy in a lot
of western and northern Europe but it
may well stick and we know the power of
Donald Trump nicknaming people so
although to us when we see Trump say
crazy Bernie it makes about as much
sense as nicknaming Elizabeth Warren
Pocahontas and sort of the distasteful
nature of it but we know that Donald
Trump's ability to nickname people in
ways that stick is strong and so I don't
think we should ignore that possibility
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram for more about
this and all other stories from today's
show at david pakman show while you're
there give me a follow on instagram at
david pakman i
posted the latest David Pakman show hey
tree at bingo card to my Instagram which
I think you'll enjoy we'll take a quick
break and unfortunately after the break
I do have to play some really sad video
for you that's coming up next I want to
tell you about a really great YouTube
channel we're partnering with it's
called
up flip TV and they've just recently
launched they've have some excellent
content for anybody interested in
business and entrepreneurship check them
out at david pakman.com slash flip
that's f li p
that'll redirect you to their youtube
channel make sure to subscribe while
you're there it is a youtube channel
that i'd recommend to anyone in the
david pakman show audience who owns a
business runs a business it's thinking
about starting a business or even if you
just like learning new things about how
business works they interview successful
entrepreneurs business owners giving
them a place to tell their stories and
share strategies so viewers can benefit
from their insight and apply their
wisdom to your own businesses all of the
content is about educating and inspiring
people in each video up flip TV
showcases a different type of startup it
could be a coffee shop or a landscaping
business or a real estate agency you'll
see how the business was often started
from scratch what a workday looks like
how to become and remain successful in
that business and they don't just
interview people they actually examine
each business from inside out in a
really unique way that distills the
valuable lessons that you can take from
their stories I find the content
fascinating they're friends of the David
Pakman show I would love it if you would
go and support their new YouTube channel
and what they're doing I think you'll
very quickly become a fan like I said
get there
by going to david pakman.com slash flip
that's FL IP and make sure to subscribe
to their channel when you're there